بعدين قاسيه معمقه وشامله للعلاقات
المتساعده التعقيد مع ايران اكد وزراء
خارجيه دول الاتحاد دعمهم لتطلعات الشعب
الايراني المشروعه نحو الحريه الوزراء
صادقوا على حزمتين من العقوبات الاضافيه
بشان تزوي طيران روسيا بالمسيرات وحمله
المسجد ضد المتظاهرين
حول حمله القمع المنهج ضد المتظاهرين
وتشمل القائمه الاضافيه واحده وعشرين
اثنان وذلك في نطاقه دعم الاتحاد للشعب
الايراني
الوزراء الاوروبيون يحذرون ايران بشده من
عواق باي دعم عسكريا اضافيا تقدمه الى
روسيا خاصه الصواريخ البالستيه قصيره
الامديه
ضد الذين يزودون روسيا سيارات تستخدمها في
قصف اوكرانيا وارتكاب جرائم الحرب هذه
المباحثات الاوروبيه شملت ايضا مازق
لاتفاق نووي حيث ابتعدت ايران عن مقتضيات
البرنامج النووي ولم تتخذ القرارات
المناسبه للتوسل الى احياء الدفاع
والعقوبات التي تصدر اليوم
الاتفاق النووي مفيد بالنسبه للجانب
الايراني
لا تزعل الحصول على تزود النوويه
الاتحاد الاوروبي عازم على ان لا تتزوج
ايران ابدا بالسلاح النووي ويدعو الدوله
كافه الى تنفيذ القرار الدولي
2231 لعام 2015 وفي ذلك رساله مباشره الى
طهران البيان الاوروبي ورد في ست صفحات
ونصف الصفحات من الرسائل التي تضمنها دعوه
الاتحاد الاوروبي ايران الى التعاوني مع
لجنه تقصي الحقائق الدوليه في العنف
المتواصلي في الداخل الايراني
وتحذير الاتحاد الاوروبي ايران من عواقب
التزويدها روسيا بالصواريخ البالسيه ان هي
فعلت او ستفعل
ويفهموا من سياق البيان الاوروبي ككل نضج
الموقف هنا
واحتمال توجهه الى مجلس الامن اذا استحاله
التفاهم مع ايران
ردينا الفريق العربيه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]